and i'm saying a sacrifice season what
are you willing to sacrifice for a
season
you'd be shocked
what's on the other side
of a couple months of freakish
discipline and focus
so thinking back over your life can you
think about a time when you were really
chasing after something a really big
goal maybe you are on a sports team and
you were trying to win the championship
maybe you have a enormous business goal
that you were trying to reach or maybe
it was something like starting a youtube
channel and you have to go through this
hard season that just kind of sucks my
friend ben azadi says that you have to
go through the suck suck suck to get to
success and in today's episode we're
talking about what i think is kind of
the sucky part of actually reaching your
goals and that is the law of sacrifice
we're gonna be talking about that
sacrifice season that can be so hard to
get through but man the success on the
other side is so worth it my name is
heather torres and i am your host of the
think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your youtube
channel and then turn that youtube
channel into a high impact and a high
profit online business and i'm so
excited if today is your first time
joining us or if you're returning to the
podcast welcome back make sure you're
subscribed wherever you're getting this
content from so if you're on youtube hit
that subscribe button if you're
listening over on apple or spotify hit
subscribe so that you make sure you're a
part of our tuesday ritual here but that
you get all of the information that we
have for you on the think media podcast
and if you're over on youtube make sure
you hit that like button and let me know
in the comments what season are you in
right now this episode is brought to you
by
thethinkholidaysale.com now this is 80
off of our brand new course bundle just
for you the think holiday sale is
helping you get to your first 1000 or
next 1000 subscribers and beyond without
a fancy camera editing experience or
spending 50 hours a week on your youtube
channel you're going to get the real and
actionable strategies speaking to the
main obstacles that are standing between
you and your youtube success we're
talking about overcoming the mindsets
that are holding you back from
conquering your fears of getting in
front of the camera and you're going to
learn how to film edit and upload your
videos with our powerful fast acting
strategies to help you gain subscribers
right now you can get all this and more
over at thinkholidaysale.com
where you're going to see 80 off during
this holiday season so make sure you go
there if you're ready to get your first
or next 1000 subscribers now this
episode is actually part of a five-part
series that we're doing here on the
podcast and we are in episode three the
third part of this series we've already
talked about the law of preparation the
law of momentum and today it's about the
law of sacrifice so if you miss those
other two episodes make sure to go back
and listen to them but stick here first
because this one is going to be amazing
now the first part of this episode is
actually a snippet from a talk that sean
did at our annual conference grow with
video live and if you want information
about how to join us at that conference
live in las vegas this year go to
growthvideolive.com i'll make sure
that's down in the show notes as well as
the description below so the first part
is actually from a talk that sean did
there and the second part of this
episode we're actually sean and i
sitting down and going deeper into what
this season actually was like for us so
make sure to stick around for that part
and we're gonna be talking about the
hardest season that i had to go through
on my youtube journey and the part that
people really quit at so i want you to
stick in stay locked and loaded and then
i'll meet you on the other side of this
[Music]
conversation the law of sacrifice you
see during the season i went all in to a
defined sacrifice season
the truth is
there is no success without sacrifice
real leaders listen
give up more than others
they just do
real leaders sacrifice more than others
it's the cost of entry
and i mentioned that between november
and december 2015 i posted 52 videos
now again
i shot every single one of those videos
i edited
every single one of those videos i vr8
you got to learn this is why i was in
the preparation season i was figuring
this out i was strengthening my content
creation messes muscles tags titles
description and i also wasn't cutting
corners if you look at them they were
thoughtful polished like they weren't
perfect
but i was putting out qual and not just
random i wasn't hitting a metric of like
oh 52 is a magic number
it was 52 videos listen following the
seven r's
every time i follow the seven r's i
follow the seven r's with with a mastery
of intention
title crudem thumbnailed them and i was
creating blog posts for them for some
backlinks and building out our video
influencers blog which i would write
extra copy and text in the blog post and
i'd create a blog version of the
thumbnail for that i would send out the
video influencers weekly newsletter and
a think media weekly newsletter sean did
you have melissa writing your newsletter
i wish i just had brian from the think
media team right there was no brian
there's no melissa there was sean
cannell i'm writing the newsletter i'm
editing the videos i'm editing the
thumbnails i'm scheduling to upload them
then i'm going to sleep with no energy
left and i'm getting up the next day and
being like man i
gotta hit this is where rise and grind
came from i got to grind these coffee
beans up dog come on sacrifice season
let's go
i got a uh i i researched and set up
some mini brand deals for think media
i got a 5k brand deal through all
negotiation it was actually beyond the
influence at the time through from being
at events and networking and talking to
people and we worked with the company
called fame bit and it was actually all
in relationship it wasn't on uh size of
influence because everything was much
smaller at that time went on a tour with
that money to la my wife and i got in a
car with our friend john drove to la
cool trip worst trip of our life i mean
everyone's cancelling honest like you
know we're hustling we're driving we're
staying in hotels the hotel has bad air
conditioning we're sleeping we're all
sleeping in the same hotel room my wife
and john and we got you know people that
are snoring and stuff's happening like
you know
like the air conditioning doesn't work
like real stuff and maybe you can relate
to this i'm talking about the real grind
friend you know this is what's happening
during these two months flew out later
to uh la again during that time i did a
side freelance project in south africa
because i needed money
also kind of cool but not that tight
like you fly to london and then south
africa in seats that are not that great
i'm still recovering from like the neck
and back structural things that happen
literally on that trip and that's true
and i mean i emailed soundcloud artists
to get dope music there wasn't epidemic
sound there wasn't there was no
royalty-free there was i don't think the
youtube library existed at this time and
i shared most of the content to the best
of my ability on social media freaking
hustling
i'm not here to flex
but i am a little bit huh like but i'm
here to say
just do you need to lean into a
sacrifice season it reminds me of what
dave ramsey says that he says this that
if you will live like no one else later
you can live like no one else
dude my life's pretty sick today
it was cool then in fact what's
interesting is i actually just live off
gratitude and thankfulness no matter
what the season is there was like a
shield of grace around me during that
time where i was tired but i was like
man this is it
i actually as soon as i lost my
freelance clients i kind of felt like it
was christmas day because i no longer
had a boss a lot of us are driven by
independence and wanting more freedom
and not wanting to be micromanaged in
all the and i was like i mean i don't
know if this is going to work but hey
let's just go for this thing
but i was putting in some really hard
work
and
with a vision
and here's the key
because this can be taken to an extreme
of toxic hustle culture
of toxic like you got to grind all the
time and never sleep and sacrifice your
health that's not what i'm saying
key word sacrifice season it's a season
and when you have that time to take the
leap this is what it takes to do a
startup when we say youtube entrepreneur
and business owner business owners know
that a lot of times it takes five years
for you even to get momentum and have
any kind of freedom from your business
those first five years are the grit are
the grind are the build and then you're
reaping later and that's a lot of times
when people sometimes they get jealous
or envious of where you were then but
they would never be willing to pay the
price that it took for you to get there
but i know you're willing to pay the
price because the point of growth video
is to prepare our minds for battle right
now to say
shoot
i think i can lean into the sacrifice
season it's just a season
and i see what it takes and here's the
the beauty of this is this is this is
the line that most
this is where most people get stuck they
go oh
this is actually actually going to take
work
i'll never forget i remember this one
guy
don't have very much respect for him uh
kind of spoils the story i should have
said at the end it would have been like
it would have hit harder but anyways uh
a guy that i just kind of knew and one
time and he purchased vra so it was this
huge thing so we have a course called
video ranking academy this i love this
story and he like he dm's he's like hey
i heard about your youtube course i'd
love to get in and i was like yeah so i
actually spent a lot of time because he
was kind of an acquaintance and then i
find she's like you know what uh
i he goes i want to take the leap and i
want to buy it now hear me
we have a refund policy we honor it
we you've been in the course you know
the course is great whatever
but this i'll never forget because i
invested a couple hours of like dming
back and forth i think we talked on the
phone
and then he finally buys it and then
he messages me
a couple weeks later and he goes hey i
got a refund you got to give me the
money back give me a refund vra and he
goes and i was like okay
of course there's kind of no questions
asked but i'm curious why and he goes
well
i got inside of the course
and i realized that this was gonna take
work
like
yeah what did you think it was like did
you just well like what kind of internet
mythical age or this is not like
unicorns and like rainbow spitting
clouds like where are you at of course
most peop that's why thomas edison said
success is missed by most people because
it's dressed in overalls and it looks
like work so then i was just super
annoyed because i was like i wish you
just would have never joined in the
first place and all of that whatever and
your reasoning it would have been one
thing if he's like i just understood you
know it was it wasn't didn't quite fit
right but literally you want to offend
the guy who who sacrificed blood sweat
and tears to build something friend you
got to commit to doing the work
write it down do
the
work
you don't have to build
you might understand i'm pretty crazy
ambitious i've got big dreams i've got
big vision but this is possible for you
and it's going to take big dreams a big
vision to get
to a 3k a month business
6k a month business to build a
consistent youtube channel but friends
the rewards on the other side
of that initial work you're going to put
in
they're worth it
they're worth it you just got to
understand the law of sacrifice
so what are you willing to sacrifice
what are you willing to sacrifice
are you willing to sacrifice comfort
and get uncomfortable
are you willing to sacrifice
the approval of others and other
people's understanding of what it is
you're building
are you willing to to sacrifice lesser
things
things that just maybe
don't matter as much don't matter or
they just don't matter for a season
are you willing to sacrifice temporary
pleasure if you if you spent half the
time or no time scrolling it might be
time to delete some apps off your phone
because again you're not going to growth
hack your youtube channel with an
instagram account
you're just not
you're not going to growth hack your
youtube channel with some other social
media i'm not against it we could talk
about that but again when you really get
focused
like you got to ask yourself are you
just spending more time scrolling and
are you just watching junk content
entertaining content news that's just
freaking you out new things information
that's just causing you more stress that
you can't change how's it helping you
build your dreams
and i'm saying a sacrifice season what
are you willing to sacrifice for a
season
you'd be shocked
what's on the other side
of a couple months of freakish
discipline and focus
you'd be absolutely astounded by what
you can accomplish
by making a radical shift sometimes
that's what our life needs not just a
few small tweaks lead to giant peaks
hashtag sean cannell you sometimes
actually need to jar yourself out of
complacency jar yourself out of comfort
and for a season build real momentum
with your youtube channel
the law of sacrifice i mean i think this
is where it really gets real of course
we want some external thing of what are
the thumbnail hacks what are the
algorithmic tricks if i get just a viral
video i don't want to deal with any of
the painful things what can i do on on
the side of hacking youtube but this is
really where the rubber hits the road
when it goes to being full-time on
youtube what are you willing to
sacrifice for your dreams what are you
willing to sacrifice for a season and i
think we should put a disclaimer out
there that both of our values are
aligned our whole company there's
certain things that you will never
sacrifice you don't sacrifice your
family or your kids or your health but
there's maybe a season where you're not
spending two hours a day in the gym
because you're not focusing on
bodybuilding in that season you're
focusing on maintaining your health but
building your business you're not
spending 14 date nights and seven days
with your spouse you're saying hey honey
let's come into alignment to really get
around some things that we're going to
sacrifice what what are some things for
you over the last really decade
that you think about that you were
willing to sacrifice for really where
you are where we are today in think
media yeah and this even goes back to
where we were on the last episode where
we're talking about that 25 role and
when i think about when we actually took
the leap um into going full time on
youtube when we decided to be a part of
think media on a massive level um and i
say we because my horse my husband
supports what i'm doing here and when i
think about that you know we were quote
unquote
living our best life meaning we my
husband had just gotten a job of a huge
job with the big promotion
we had just got a house the biggest
house we had ever lived on on a golf
course we were you know doing all the
things right all the things that i
thought were what we wanted for success
but i knew
that in order to make what the reality
of youtube for us really happened
we were going to have to downsize our
life because we were living to the top
of what our income was right we were
there wasn't anything extra there wasn't
anything to be able to say no when we
take the sleep we'll have uh we need to
have some margin built in there and so
for us personally you know we we moved
we downsized our house half the size
with two kids at the time we have three
now uh we decided to i call it we just
dave ramsey'd it meaning like we just
sold everything we sold tvs we sold uh
snowboards we sold anything that was in
our garage that we were like how can we
just get a hold of cash so that we can
actually take the sleep so that my
husband can leave his job so that i can
be full-time on youtube so we can do
this as a thing
and some people aren't willing to do
that you know we actually so really
evaluated where we were and we could
have just kept doing what we were doing
and been completely comfortable but we
needed to get uncomfortable in a season
so that we could build something of
bigger impact and so you know
sacrificing even just the
outward appearance of a great life you
know we really downsized and we just
said i don't need to shop at target
let's go to goodwill and we were making
good money and we said no we're not
going to do that we're going to downsize
we're not going to eat out we're going
to get a
coffee maker at home heather so you
don't go to starbucks like all those
pieces
monetarily were what we sacrifice when i
think about what i sacrificed in the
season of building
i don't really watch a lot of movies not
that that's a bad thing but i would
rather be spending my time in a learning
mode or doing mode um i would we would
say no to going on trips with people or
going to do things on the weekend and
all of those pieces and and that's the
stuff that people don't see and it's
hard and it sucks actually right now our
family could have been in disneyland but
i was like no we need to shoot these
podcasts that was a sacrifice and it's
still in the season and it's just
weighing the pros and cons of what is
actually your priorities um for building
how about you well i just think that the
downsize hack like is one of the hacks
like or or making sure you when your
income even goes up that you don't
increase your living at the same time
people put unnecessary stress or it's
all i mean this is it's freedom of
choice do whatever you want but they
they create when they when you increase
your living and you increase your
expenses and then you also say well i
also want to build my youtube channel
but you have all the stress you have to
take over time at work still
as opposed to maybe scaling back your
hours at work so you have more time to
work on your side hustle man i just
absolutely love that down size hack sony
and i have tried to do the same we've uh
we've all i mean we only recently
in le for less than a year we've been
homeowners besides back during the big
short um we've been renting way before
we do even when we hit targets at think
media where we could have been like oh
now let's start having some outward
symbols of success right
we we just didn't go into that but even
in those early days keeping your
expenses low thinking about can you
downsize that car can you move into a
smaller house because the question is
what is the vision if you really want to
be full-time on youtube what are you
willing to sacrifice today for tomorrow
we mentioned the dave ramsey quote if
you will just live a few years that's a
big word years of your life like no one
else then for the rest of your life you
could live like no one else and so you
know that reminds me there's a a proverb
it's very it's really well known in the
bible that says where there is no vision
the people cast off restraint
and another translation talks about when
you don't have a vision there's not
discipline there i think the thing with
this sacrifice season
is if you're not clear on where it is
you want to go and like the light at the
end of the tunnel then you won't pay the
price today like if you don't get really
clear about the six-pack abs that you
want then you won't eat the salad today
that's i'm not very clear about the the
six-pack abs apparently because i'm not
eating the salad today but but i was
clear that i wanted to be full-time on
youtube i was clear of of wanting to be
able to uh have that freedom and so i
would ask think media podcast listeners
what is your vision
like even feel it a little bit imagine
what's it gonna feel like when you can
not only get up and do the work you love
but
when you actually get past the sacrifice
season it won't be this way forever
you mentioned it we're still sacrificing
today but it's a whole different vibe
today it was like chaos wondering if we
were going to survive
praying like i just hope we can keep and
and now with where the team has gone
where some stability has gotten
certainly we i would we are comfortable
financially now yeah we were not
comfortable at all we were terrified
financially at that at that time yeah
sacrifice season therefore you don't if
you if resources are tight
every resource counts and you don't want
to be wasting you know money on
unnecessary things what's your vision
jesus
he said it it says for the joy set
before him he endured the cross he had a
vision for the saving of humanity and
that we would be reconciled to him as
sons and daughters that we
and so he was willing to endure the
cross
what's your cross what's the cross you
need to carry today what's the sacrifice
you need to face today yeah i mean you
mentioned i i said a lot of them in that
talk but
it could be comfort you're right it
wasn't netflix and movies but today we
were just spending all lunch during the
shoot talking about the shows we're
binging or whatever it's a different
season now absolutely we still pay the
price because
if you need in leadership if you want to
go up you got to keep giving up and
sometimes that's giving up rights and
sometimes that's giving up what other
people um but but nevertheless there is
a particular season in that gap between
nine to five and full time in that gap
between your part-time job and full-time
on youtube between that gap of really
making this thing work and sometimes you
gotta sacrifice yeah and i think it goes
down to just the law of focus you know
when i think about even like tony the
director here at think media producer
here at think media um he i remember
when he said he wanted to join video
ranking academy and he said you know we
actually just looked at our bills and we
said
we're gonna just cancel all like what if
i spent the money that i usually spend
on netflix and hulu and these other
things what if i spent that for a few
months until i could start making some
money or maybe a year but when i can
start making some money on actual
youtube education because that's my
dream you know and when i think about
even that sacrifice season and what it
felt like it felt like immense focus and
everything else was no i mean we
i health is important i sacrificed a lot
of sleep during that time i still had
two little kids that i was homeschooling
while we were doing this so a lot of
times it was you know during the nap
times in the morning getting up super
early i hate waking up early still i
hate it but it's a sacrifice of knowing
that if i can have two hours of focused
intentional time to figure out the next
video idea to figure out what the cost
of the course should be to figure out
the um or make the thumbnail that is two
hours that i'll never get back and i
want to make sure that i'm sacrificing
in small ways because each one of those
small things small tweaks do lead to
giant peaks
but definitely in that sacrifice it's
just immense focus that you have to have
and i like that you brought up tony
because yeah people don't know his story
now he is the executive producer at
think media but he joined video ranking
academy went through it all twice too he
didn't just join an online course he
actually committed to it went through it
bought a plane ticket him and his wife
came to grow with video live in person
um and it set off a series of events
even before they joined the team they
started getting momentum on their
youtube channels plant-based kitchen
puts out a video that ranks in regards
to the airbnb space with affiliate
marketing at the time like it's really
impacting his stuff by the way if it
wasn't for those signals of him putting
in the work he wouldn't have even made
it onto the team in the first place
because he was an action taker and so he
was living the law of sacrifice it kind
of brings up too like who's in your
world because you mentioned this is very
hard it's very hard when everyone around
you is going on vacation but you aren't
it's very hard when your circle of
friends just bought the 20 newest model
of a car when they just added a pool to
their backyard probably leveraging
disproportionate debt but who knows that
keeping up with the jones's thing can
really mess with you
we are i feel insulated because think
media's culture and our ethos
is like the law of sacrifice like i
respect kyle anderson so much because
just recently he just got the sickest
jeep rubicon but there's so much
blessing on that car because he's been
driving a 2021
uh subaru
car
for 20 oh 2001. yeah two not 20 21. he
corrected me here at 2001 the car
subaru impreza
paint 2.5 rs paint is chipping off
200 000 plus miles and every single time
i see that car i'm like respect dog
because the interesting thing is so many
stages along the way easy you can go
anybody any of us can go right now oh
man i just need that new level up man
i'm going to go to a car dealership get
into a payment he has kept his living
low
and and there's also there's another
level of gratitude when you reach
certain places
you know i heard one guy put it this way
he said don't eat
for
you know breakfast what god intended for
dinner come on i think sometimes we rush
into
an inheritance gain too early won't be
blessed in the end now hear me like get
whatever car you want i guess you know
get whatever house you want but people
take on too much stress when they have
too much debt too many expenses and when
you're doing a startup a youtube channel
youtube entrepreneur a business
it's about funneling
laser focus you're funneling your money
your time your resources to get to
create momentum the theme of the last
episode that then gets you you're
sacrificing all your resources in one
direction to hit that breakthrough
moment
and back to vision what is your vision
because we saw what were happening we
didn't know exactly was going to look
like this but we did know what we were
fighting for we were fighting for
freedom for our families we were
fighting for financial freedom we were
fighting for the ability to work on our
own time to be able to continue to still
work hard but to take time off and
whatever we want we make our own
schedule completely we were fighting for
doing something we love and making an
impact we were fighting for being able
to work in a in a culture where we set
the culture and it's not dictated by
some
boss or corporate where it's like man
that's kind of toxic here like i don't
want to go to work because the
environment we get to create the
environment and so what are you fighting
for
if there is no vision there's not going
to be discipline yeah but the reason
you'll have the discipline to endure the
cost and the cross and the sacrifice
today is because you've got a clear
vision of what you're fighting for in
your future yeah and you said it and i
want to just reiterate this write this
down again do the work
when you're in that sacrifice season do
the work because just because you're
sacrificing we see that too oh well i
mean i'm not doing do the freaking work
and you're gonna see the fruits of that
labor but when you're in that season you
know for us it definitely and i think
this stems for all creators it comes
down to financially where are you at
what can you sacrifice how much time and
money can you be putting into your
vision and then just go for it and do
the work and commit to the work and it's
funny to say money because a couple
weeks back on the podcast we broke down
that study
of 1400 full-time content creators and
they discovered that the median income
they had invested in their business with
ten to ten thousand dollars
that's also the sacrifice of dollars the
sacrifice to buy a camera to invest in
coaching to buy a course to buy a
standing desk and a web camera and
lighting and all but you mentioned it it
actually on the other side of focus you
can come up with ten thousand dollars
yeah even if you don't earn ten thousand
more you you trim out some things of
your life you reduce your living you
decide to
shrink
or a thousand square feet in your court
like just what are you willing to
sacrifice
and how serious are
you about the target that you're going
for man the law of sacrifice i'm loving
this series so funny and i'm pumped we
got two more weeks where we're just
going through these pillars and again i
want to encourage the think media
podcast community
we are so serious about our mission to
get you to full time but we hope that
you feel like we're we're telling it
straight like this isn't this is this
definitely this isn't good marketing no
this is horrible marketing we're like
hey here's the secret to go full time
pain staking
sacrifice
here's here's your path to full time
pick up your cross
and carry it through the valley of death
do all the hard work and see no fruit
from it for five years for years do you
want a magic pill five years later
but i mean this is the real stuff and
this is the fastest growing small
business type this is absolutely a real
destination that you can put out on your
calendar but i hope that you're hearing
the nitty gritty of man what it really
takes to get there so stick with us i
can't wait for these next two weeks in
this series and uh to get into the next
one soon
well i hope that conversation left you
with something to think about and i have
a question for you what are you willing
to sacrifice in this season is it
comfort is it the approval of others
maybe actually feeling that there's
things that are in your life that don't
really matter that you just need to get
rid of you need to sacrifice those
things so that you can stay laser
focused on what your goal is maybe it's
the temporary pleasures maybe you want
to do a 30-day social media detox so you
can just focus on actually creating
rather than consuming what do you need
to sacrifice in this season if you have
a journal out and you're actually taking
notes during this session i want you to
actually think about that maybe take
just a few minutes to really think about
what do i need to sacrifice so that i
can get to my goals now if you're
driving in the car just think in your
head don't pull over just keep going but
really be thinking about this over this
next week of where do you need to
sacrifice so that you can reach your
goals now i want to say thank you to all
of our think community members who are
over on itunes and rating and reviewing
this podcast it helps us so much to be
able to get this podcast into the ears
of those who need to hear it i want to
thank anti drew today who left the
comment value value value the think
podcasters are providing tons of value
dropping youtube gold all caps in every
episode if you're interested in building
your business on youtube or building a
youtube business this is a podcast you
can't miss anti-drew thank you so much
for saying that that is really our heart
behind this we want to help you build a
youtube business we want to help you
build your business on youtube it's
really what has changed our lives and we
just want to help and inspire and
encourage as many people as we can to do
the same thing now i have one more
special announcement for you if you made
it this long in the podcast you are my
favorite person can i just tell you that
because you're listening still to this
special announcement and that is we are
hiring here at think media we have so
many positions available right now our
team is massively growing we have
full-time part-time and paid internships
available at
workwiththink.com if you've ever thought
about being a part of a movement of
creators being a part of a team that is
uplifting inspiring and encouraging then
this is the right step for you
we have positions in creative admin pr
and so much more so make sure if you're
interested to go to
workwiththink.com so you can apply today
now i want to thank you so much for
being a part of our think community
thank you for listening if you didn't
catch the first two parts of this series
make sure to go back and listen to those
the law of preparation and the law of
momentum are so powerful and then next
week we're going to be jumping into the
business side of youtube i can't wait to
see you on the next podcast and i'll
talk to you soon bye did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle
get over 1
hundred dollars worth of our best
courses tools templates and more just go
to thinkmediasale.com
[Music]
you